in Hungary protests erupted in January
at one EU flags waved hi at another EU
flag to have burned the media reports
that a battle is brewing between
Budapest and Brussels we went to the
Hungarian capital to see what the real
story is 1300 kilometers away from
Brussels in Budapest the temperature was
minus 5 but the political temperature
towards the EU varied voila or Amelia
Moyes viscosity Cody Allen Poe
Democratic ooh [ __ ] a tack majority
share medeiros eggwin mom Ocean Avenue
tunic with nem shop mindd include
knocked any other language has McGee
shockula carnivore tonic excellent thank
next poker machine Charles Missouri when
you pass a rope a parliament and now
gone de la Mina's desi could you do me
minted a mother or segment to be kishore
sec babu kajal chuckwalla keanu central
beneath my be rakesh on a couch care to
Eternia Mindy calendario past where you
know you gon do not plan oh yeah
analogies urban Oh integral of e to do
knock our political Jurgis may like a
shaggy dog leash the media has been very
active in Brussels following heated
exchanges about the situation in Hungary
since it held the EU presidency last
year when you say before we were
dictated to by Moscow and now it's
Brussels you actually mean it you've
proved to be the secret weapon of the
Euroskeptic movement poor koala in
Malibu see dollar p pasilla dyson
politique de fan purity keep al-din
certain man yeah he see if you not
romagna don't laugh p is his sake female
hello Bob more recently a hearing in
Brussels EU commissioner neelie kroes
and Hungarian Deputy Prime Minister
tibor never axis didn't always see eye
to eye editor of center right blog
Medina thinks the situation is being
exaggerated there were many funny things
and all the posters the situation in
Hungary night next to the Mafia's of
Europe and the size things like many EU
countries the Hungarian media is divided
on left
lines a new media law was approved by
the two-thirds majority finish
government some argue is tip the balance
in favor of the ruling party which means
reporting and Brussels could become
distorted there is no public discourse
and one can see that unfortunately that
might have been the goal of the
government so in that system the whole
system is messed up and I'm not using
the effort that I could use it January
thirteenth was the first day journalists
from index could enter the Parliament
after being banned it was also the day
when the hunger march reached the
capital certain journalists were amongst
the protesters estilo threat for most
journalists make promoting
self-censorship so it's better not to
say something which is unfavorable of
the government because you will pay the
consequences you can lose your job and
you can maybe be in a position that you
will never find the Japanese government
is in place most admit the media laws
are not perfect however the offices of
right-wing paper manijeh one of the most
notorious journalists wasn't surprised
I'd spoken with the former mtv editor
kima hasta alla Tony mayor o segundo
novice obodo needy hasta lehtonen
maduros ago Fenig 80 kosuge ageru yo
tenia torma distort a nazi alero ha
bolero Giornale mochi mochi on pasta
chalindo lo tuvo cockatoos ash or
syndulla to video kapoor also check our
laughs when newspaper Nev sabah el pez
know everyone's work he's been affected
by the changes n media lo enemies de
mucho tova bro samui fennen paris to
vomit later okay inca bobany suharto's
asteroid or aku mentally that could have
gone with a barkeeper missed it hurt
Emil the lucrative men's 192nd origami
toes with shayna ish Tsukasa guru
Banaszak or romantic at mynt Korriban
ella trabaja toccatas ash to geneva more
on Pedro Cruz media are too low to talk
or 950 rania water too schuco
keyence often alberta acosta Turkish
media is sarah with a population of 10
million market forces aren't strong
enough to ensure the diversity of media
ownership the first communist country
has always struggled against state
intervention in the media for almost two
decades hungry in public kind of used to
the fact that there is the leftish media
and there is the rightish media and the
leftish part is only writing good things
about leftist political parties and the
rightish part rights only good things
about the rightish political parties
this must be changed I don't think it's
an exaggeration to say that independent
media is barley existing today in in
Hungary whilst in Budapest from left to
right or well Ian references little
people speech the one thing or may not
have been proud of is the legacy of big
brother no most assault a soup me
casazza move on voila quiere la Cour lo
que pedo con air helluva sea bueno cos
or he go mobile oh la la bubi lago con
technology deported our tomo durante las
horas rodigan dhoni lahusen el dia de
Sade de enero pas bon jour pour lui my
data here take again you can take even
solace the new media law was supposed to
clean up what many source that depraved
Big Brother style programs but also
raises fears about state control of the
media Orwell's Whiting's a reminder of
what absolute power entails when
reporting battles with the EU freedom of
the press is crucial for journalists
remain critical of any institution
whether based in Brussels or very
depressed